well brian as las vegas slowly opens
back up
mgm resorts is taking its cobit 19
precautions to the next level
guests will now have the option to get a
kobig 19 test
in their room as joe moeller explains
this is all part of the company's health
and safety program he joins us live on
the strip
near several mgm properties to explain
joe
yeah well leaders at mgm resorts tell me
that this has been in the works for
months now as more people have been
coming here to las
vegas the goal is to provide more
options for guests and to make them feel
as safe as possible while visiting
las vegas it's a great idea
mgm resorts is making copin 19 related
changes at their properties
guests now can get a copin 19 test in
their room especially if you're going to
somewhere that
you have to have the test before flying
out people probably would take advantage
of it
and that is one of the reasons why the
tests are there as we've brought
a lot of folks back and more visitors
are coming back to vegas
there's a couple of things that we
started to get a lot of guest questions
about
how can i get tested john flynn is the
vice president of administration at mgm
resorts
he says there are a few in-room test
options one provide results in 24 to 72
hours
the other in 20 minutes tests cost
between 140 and 230 dollars
results are delivered electronically we
just wanted to
give you know a sense of comfort and
and and to ease you know our our
customers minds
also part of mgm's convene with
confidence plan are options for large
events and conventions event organizers
are able to choose coping 19 related
precautions for
events such as health screenings site
cleaning protocols
and physical distancing that's an
exciting move for us not
not just for mgm resorts because
obviously we get to bring more employees
back to work
as we get to scale these up but it's
great for the industry it's great for
the city right at large
guests appreciate the options that's one
of the things that we've seen and
appreciated about las vegas there's a
lot of customer service
and so i think that's just another way
to extend that
now back out here live as more people
get the vaccine mgm resorts is looking
at
options for convention organizers to add
proof of vaccine to their criteria
for attendees and again that will be an
option for the organizers reporting live
here near the strip joe mohler 8 news
now